son las ocho y treinta de la noche en
Bogotá quito y Lima continuamos en
directo América edición nocturna
seguimos comentándoles los principales
hechos del día Les agradecemos su
sintonía y vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
las armas de fuego se cobraron otras
seis víctimas en Estados Unidos tres de
ellas menores de 9 años que perdieron la
vida en un tiroteo dentro de una escuela
de la ciudad de Nashville la presunta
autora que estaba Armada con dos rifles
de asalto y una pistola murió por
disparos de las autoridades
en Ecuador son siete los fallecidos y 46
dos desaparecidos tras un deslizamiento
registrado en el sur del país las
Fuertes lluvias causaron el deslave que
deja más de 500 afectados al tiempo que
14 provincias están bajo estado de
emergencia
la presión social acorraló al Primer
Ministro de Israel Benjamín de tanyahu
que se vio forzado a posponer su
polémica reforma judicial las continuas
movilizaciones hicieron que el
mandatario suspendiera las votaciones de
la ley de elección de jueces que podía
ser aprobada esta semana
[Aplausos]
[Música]
damos inicio en la ciudad de Nashville
que es el escenario del último episodio
de una serie de tiroteos mortales en
escuelas de Estados Unidos una mujer de
28 años fuertemente Armada es la
sospechosa de asesinar a tres niños y a
tres integrantes del personal de una
escuela presbiteriana Por el momento no
se conoce el móvil del ataque pero sí
que la mujer portaba dos rifles de
asalto una pistola y tenía un mapa del
colegio donde ella misma había sido
estudiante Lee Israel tiene los detalles
nueva escena de terror en Estados Unidos
una mujer abrió fuego con dos rifles de
asalto y una pistola en Land School una
escuela cristiana Privada de Nashville y
mató a tres niños y tres miembros
educativos la presunta atacante fue
abatida por la policía
hemos identificado la sospechosa es una
mujer de 28 años Blanca originaria de
Nashville o que vive en la zona
mis hallazgos iniciales es que en un
momento dado ella era un estudiante en
esa escuela pero no estoy seguro En qué
año
si bien las mujeres que disparan de
forma masiva son extremadamente escasas
los tiroteos en centros escolares se han
convertido en algo alarmantemente
frecuentes en los últimos años en
Estados Unidos pero los llamamientos del
presidente para que el congreso
restablezca la prohibición Nacional de
los fusiles de asalto se han topado con
la oposición de los republicanos
Defensores acérrimos del derecho
constitucional aportar armas Es
simplemente enfermizo aún estamos
reuniendo las pruebas de lo que sucedió
Y por qué sucedió sabemos que hay un
número de personas que no van a
sobrevivir incluidos niños es
desgarrador la peor pesadilla
Así que pido al congreso de nuevo que
apruebe mi prohibición de armas de
asalto en lo que va del 2023 se
produjeron 129 tiroteos masivos
definidos Así cuando cuatro o más
personas fueron tiroteadas o asesinadas
según datos del
y pasamos a Ecuador donde las Fuertes
lluvias han provocado un deslizamiento
de tierra en el sur del país las
autoridades rectificaron que siete
personas y no 16 han fallecido al tiempo
que hay 46 desaparecidos y 500 afectados
que han perdido o sufrido daños en sus
viviendas el deslave fue provocado por
las Fuertes lluvias que mantienen a 14
provincias bajo estado de emergencia
Alba Santana tiene los detalles
tragedia en el sur de Ecuador tras las
intensas lluvias en la localidad de la
UCI un deslizamiento de tierra se saldó
con la vida de varias personas dejando
algunas casas cubiertas de lodo y otras
totalmente destruidas
un tremendo sonido
El Fuerte temporal deja al menos 500
damnificados y varios desaparecidos que
ahora los equipos de rescate y los
voluntarios se esfuerzan por encontrar
aquí sobre 20 metros de material pétreo
que cubre un estadio y abajo entre la
desolación de los vecinos en la conocida
como nariz del [__] por su pronunciada
pendiente El Ejecutivo de lazo prometió
actuar para ayudar a Los afectados el
gobierno está totalmente activo enfocado
en la tragedia de
tanto la dirección de riesgos cuerpo de
bomberos fuerzas armadas policía la Cruz
Roja el Ministerio de salud pública y el
Ministerio de bienestar social más allá
de la UCI las Fuertes lluvias han
destruido carreteras puentes y otras
infraestructuras en todo el país solo en
lo que va de año se han reportado
987 incidentes peligrosos relacionados
con las precipitaciones por lo que el
gobierno declaró estado de emergencia en
14 provincias cientos de profesores
venezolanos marcharon una vez más este
lunes para exigir mejores condiciones
laborales y la renuncia de la ministra
de Educación los profesores han
asegurado que los salarios ni siquiera
alcanzan para comprar comida en marzo de
2022 El Ejecutivo fijó el salario mínimo
en 130 bolívares que equivalían entonces
a unos 30 dólares y que debido a la
inflación se han visto reducidos a poco
más de cinco dólares una canasta básica
cuesta alrededor de 90 salarios mínimos
según estimaciones del centro de
documentación y análisis social de la
Federación de maestros
inició la campaña para los comicios
generales del 25 de junio en Guatemala y
este lunes miles de indígenas y
campesinos guatemaltecos protestaron y
bloquearon carreteras del país para
pedir que se acabe la corrupción y que
el poder judicial permita la candidatura
de la única fórmula presidencial que
postula a una mujer indígena las
movilizaciones se producen luego de que
la oea expresara su preocupación por el
desarrollo del proceso electoral
guatemalteco al argumentar que los
mecanismos establecidos para
impugnaciones y exclusiones de
candidaturas generan incertidumbre y
tensiones para analizar este tema
conectamos con Renzo Rosales catedrático
de la universidad Rafael landívar
licenciado en ciencias políticas y
sociales bienvenido France 24 Qué está
pasando con el proceso electoral en
Guatemala porque hay preocupaciones
decir se puede hablar de razones de peso
para excluir a los candidatos a quienes
no se les permitió la inscripción hasta
este momento
Bueno un aspecto fundamental en un
proceso electoral es que
no haya discrecionalidad o inclusive
decisiones de carácter arbitrario y que
las exclusiones que se puedan dar sea
sobre la base de razonamiento jurídicos
en el caso de Guatemala en el marco de
lo que persecutúa la ley electoral y de
partidos políticos cuando cuando Esto no
es así cuando se aplica lo contrario
cuando se me aplican decisiones que tal
parecería que tienen una un mercado
sentido de orientación política y cuando
el órgano electoral en el caso de
Guatemala el tribunal supremo electoral
toma decisiones tal parecería también
acomodaticias pues el proceso en sí
mismo va tornándose se va empañando y
ese es el tono de las elecciones de este
año curso del año 2023 marcadas por eso
por una tonalidad cada vez más gris un
proceso disminuido que no arroja
Esperanza que no arroje ilusión a la
ciudadanía sino todo lo contrario y hoy
este día lunes que inicia el proceso
electoral tal parecería que es bastante
insípido y los donde los partidos en
lugar de llenar de lugar de plantear
propuestas programas prioridades
elementos sustantivos se están desde ya
planteándose toda una presencia
mediáticas pero que no lo que genera es
dispersión en la ciudadanía puntualmente
qué es lo que ocurre en el caso de la
candidata indígena a la presidencia
Telma Cabrera
bueno el partido que le impulso es el
partido liberación de los pobres que
tuvo una participación importante en las
elecciones de 2019 que ocupó el cuarto
lugar y en esta ocasión postulan como
candidato a la vicepresidencia a el
procurador de los Derechos Humanos el
licenciado Jordan Rodas y tal parecería
que él se convierte se ha convertido en
una digamos una piedra en el zapato y el
en el elemento central entonces de
dejarlos fuera de la del proceso obedece
más bien a razones de carácter político
especialmente orientados a la no
presencia de El señor Jordan Rodas quien
durante su paso a la derechos humanos
llevó a cabo una serie de acciones que
fueron considerados por diversos grupos
en el país como digamos como elementos
que hoy por hoy son se usa como anularlo
y la decisión entonces de dejarlo fuera
es Está marcado por eso por un nivel de
falta discrecionalidad usted estaba
mencionando algo de esto y se lo
pregunto puntualmente se puede hablar de
poca transparencia falta de criterio
jurídico como argumentan algunas
organizaciones a la hora de inscribir
aspirantes porque por ejemplo Hay
personas condenadas o señaladas por
delitos como corrupción y narcotráfico
Me parece que esos correctos a
valoraciones se han aplicado una serie
de decisiones que tal parecería como de
la de la puerta giratoria te dejan
entrar algunos y se obstaculiza la
participación de otros ese elemento
insisto se convierte en un elemento
fundamental en un proceso electoral y lo
empaña desde un inicio pues Señor rosala
usted muchas gracias por su análisis y
por compartirlo con nosotros en France
24 un placer un gusto cambiamos de tema
porque la atención internacional a lo
largo de la jornada estuvo enfocada en
Israel allí el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu pospuso el debate y votación
sobre la ley que plantea varias
modificaciones al sistema judicial el
mandatario Indicó que dará una espera
para explicar el proyecto en detalle
para fomentar un diálogo con diferentes
sectores políticos y sociales para
negociar su aprobación esto tras semanas
de multitudinarias manifestaciones
ciudadanas y una huelga general en
rechazo a la propuesta
ante la presión de la calle de la
oposición y de su propio partido
Benjamín finalmente cambio de postura
en nombre de la responsabilidad nacional
y para evitar divisiones entre nuestro
pueblo
He decidido pausar la segunda y la
tercera lectura del proyecto de ley
durante esta sesión de la kenneced
para dar tiempo y alcanzar este amplio
consenso
golpeado pero no hundido el Primer
Ministro anunció que el proyecto de ley
se reanudará el próximo mes de abril
después de pesaj la Pascua judía la
posición israelí se declaró dispuesta al
diálogo pero bajo ciertas condiciones
hemos tenido malas experiencias en el
pasado así que nos aseguraremos de que
no haya trucos si intenta algo se
encontrará frente a él a cientos de
miles de israelíes Patriotas decididos a
luchar por nuestra democracia lo mismo
manifestó Benny gangs
nos presentaremos en la residencia del
presidente y le tendremos la mano pido a
netanyahu que no añada amenazas
ultimátums y declaraciones extremas que
nos alejen de nuestro destino detengan
todo y envíen las delegaciones
apropiadas
tras el discurso del Primer Ministro el
principal sindicato de funcionarios
levantó la convocatoria de huelga
general pero el momento de la
apaciguamiento no parece haber llegado
todavía
dos bandos continuaron enfrentándose en
la noche en las calles de tel aviv
una jornada de huelgas en el transporte
público por lo que el servicio de trenes
autobuses y aeropuertos se vio afectado
los trabajadores exigieron que sus
salarios aumenten debido a la alta
inflación que atraviesa la economía más
grande de Europa
una huelga por el aumento salarial que
detiene el transporte en Alemania
trabajadores de aeropuertos puertos
ferrocarriles autobuses y líneas de
metro atendieron el llamado de las
centrales sindicales verdi ibg para
parar por 24 horas
nos encontramos en negociaciones
colectivas estamos en huelga hoy porque
la inflación nos está golpeando muy
fuerte Los costos de calefacción son
extremos de la gasolina es extremo
tenemos que pensar cada vez que vamos de
compras
llevamos esto o no necesitamos el dinero
para financiar nuestra vida y por eso
estamos aquí
financiero
verde representa alrededor de 2,5
millones de empleados del sector público
y exige Un aumento del 10,5% en los
salarios en tanto de vejez que
representa 230.000 trabajadores en los
ferrocarriles y en las empresas de
autobuses Busca un aumento del 12%, la
ministra del interior de Alemania está a
cargo de las negociaciones
presentamos una buena ahora espero que
los sindicatos se alejen de sus altas
demandas y se reúnan con nosotros en
algún lugar del camino la inflación en
Alemania llegó al 9,3% anual en febrero
según la oficina Federal de estadística
debido a la guerra en Ucrania que hizo
que los precios de los alimentos y la
energía se dispararan lo mismo ocurre en
el resto de Europa que lucha por
contener la inflación en Reino Unido que
llegó a más del 10%, los trabajadores
del sector público y privado han
emprendido jornadas de huelga para
exigir mejores salarios
pasamos a Ucrania porque el gobierno de
kiev confirmó que los primeros tanques
británicos Challenger ya llegaron a
territorio ucraniano esto al tiempo que
el Ministerio de defensa alemán ratificó
que fueron entregados los primeros 18
tanques leopardos mientras se prepara el
envío de un centenar de leopard 1
financiados en conjunto con Dinamarca y
Países Bajos Berlín explicó que además
fueron suministrados 40 blindados y las
municiones necesarias
apoyamos a Ucrania con entregas de armas
y especialmente con el entrenamiento
militar que ambos países brindan
Alemania y Países Bajos han entregado
conjuntamente vehículos blindados de
combate de Infantería y municiones Y
actualmente se está preparando junto con
Dinamarca la entrega de tanques de
batalla principales leopard 1 Para
apoyar a Ucrania también de esta manera
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega a malbecnotman con toda la
información del continente africano en
África 7 días feliz noche para todos
[Música]